بيجين وقد خلت شوارعها من الحركه بعد
ارتفاع ملحوظ في عدد المصابين بفيروس
كورونا بالمدينه على غرار مدن ومناطق عده
في انحاء الصين
في الوقت الحالي هناك مزيد من حالات
الاصابه بالفيروس
19 التي اكتشفت خلال الفحص الجماعي
في العاصمه تاتي في اللحظه الاكثر حرجا
كعادتها كلما انتشر الفيروس في العاصمه
منعت السلطات المطاعم من استقبال الزبائن
واغلقت مجمعات سكنيه كشف فيها عن حالات
اصابه بالفايروس على سكانها
وفرض على المواطنين والمقيمين اجراء
اختبار الكشف عن الفيروس يوميا بعد ان كان
مقصورا على مره واحده كل ثلاثه ايام
اجراءات اصبح لها اثر كبير على حياه
السكان ومعيشتهم
كان لها تاثير كبير على حياتنا
لكنني واثقه من اننا سننتصر في النهايه
على الوباء
سياسه صفر كوفد التي تمسكت بها الحكومه
الصينيه منذ بدء الجائحه للسيطره على
الفيروس وحمايه السكان يبدو انها تاتي
بنتائج عكسيه فبينما تحتاج الحكومه الى
التخلص من اعباء التكاليف الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه
لاجراءاتها صارمه تخشى في الوقت نفسه
عواقب وقيمه جرات تعيشي مع فيروس
يمكنه ان يفتك بمجتمع يتسم بالشيخوخه يقول
خبراء اذا توجهت الصين نحو التعايش مع
الفيروسات فان احد اكبر التحديات يكمله في
كيفيه تعاملها مع موجه واسعه من الاصابات
الجديده خصوصا بين كبار السن وقد يعدل فشل
في التعامل مع هذا التحدي الى اثاره موجه
غضبا
ثقيله اجتماعيه الحكومه الصينيه في غنى
عنها
ناصر عبد الحق الجزيره بيجين